hey 42 here in a few minutes I'll tell
you why this bird could be the secret to
unlocking skills you never thought you
had what if you could wake up tomorrow
and play the piano despite never having
touched a musical instrument what if you
could suddenly paint like d viny despite
never having put brush to canvas in the
very near future this and much more
might be possible and if you stick
around until the end you'll find out
exactly why that is and what a small
Australian bird has to do with it
[Music]
all but first let me ask you a question
who do you think Drew This Magnificent
geometric
painting to answer that we need to go
back to 2002 on the street outside a
karaoke bar in Tacoma Washington a
humble Furniture salesman named Jason
padget had just enjoyed a few drinks and
was leaving the bar when it hit
him a blow to the back of the head padet
was tragically mugged and violently
beaten Jason padet was an ordinary man
until suddenly he
wasn't before the mugging he had zero
interest in arts maths or geometry he
was a regular guy with two main
attributes a brown belt in karate and he
could sell the holy shite out of a
reasonably priced futon after the
mugging however padet woke up as though
he'd been plugged into the Matrix and
Han had chosen the Math's genius floppy
disc to upload to his brain suddenly
padet saw the world in a very different
light
literally he had developed synesthesia a
condition where people see the world
through other senses other than sight
such as smell touch or color in Pet's
case he started to see the world through
the lens of
geometry everywhere he looked he saw
angles prisms light rays and tangents
once more he began drawing the most
beautifully intricate geometric images
entirely by hand his art work has been
widely celebrated and padet is now also
a skilled mathematician but most
remarkably of all when asked he said he
viewed the violent mugging as a gift
what a man padet is an example of one of
the two types of
svant most sants are congenital svants
which means they are born with the
syndrome and exhibit incredible mental
Feats from
childhood padet however is the second
kind an acquired Sant someone who
acquired svant syndrome later in life
usually following a brain
injury savants are often featured in
documentaries and films but have you
actually ever met one in real life I'm
willing to bet the answer is no because
Savant syndrome is rare like really
really rare about one in 100 children
are diagnosed with
autism and of those Savant syndrome only
presents in one in 1,000 cases so it's
estimated that anywhere from 1 in
100,000 to 1 in 1 million people are
sants and that's congenital svant
acquired svant syndrome is rarer still
there are fewer than 50 cases in the
entire
world oh and there's also a super duper
special category of sants within sants
they're called Mega sants and there are
only a handful that have been identified
throughout recorded
history the most famous is Kim Peak but
you probably know him as Rainman
contrary to popular belief Kim Peak
wasn't actually autistic he had a rarer
condition called FG syndrome which is a
slightly different mental
disability but that certainly didn't
hold that Peak from reaching the peak of
human
performance peak's m attribute was his
uncanny photographic memory he could
accurately recall the contents of at
least 12,000 books what's more he would
read a book by using his left eye to
scan the left Page whilst his right eye
simultaneously read the right page
despite reading two pages at the same
time he still remembered every single
detail Peak could also provide driving
directions between almost any two cities
in the world and he was able to
confidently answer which day of the week
it was on any given date in history in
fact calendar calculations such as this
are a very common theme among sants for
some unknown reason it's a talent that
many of them
exhibit others such as Leslie lmka have
talent in the musical realm despite
sadly not being able to feed himself or
walk properly lmka could listen to any
piece of music just once and then
perfectly recite it on the piano from
MOS start to
chaikovsky yet he'd never had any
musical
training then there's the incredible
Daniel tamit who can recite every digit
of pi to
22514 decimal
places Alonzo Clemens is able to see any
animal just once then within a few hours
sculpts an exact and highly detailed
replica using only his bare hands Steven
Wilshire is known as the human camera
because he can draw an incredibly
accurate and highly detailed cityscape
after glimpsing a city just once he has
drawn incredible panoramas of London New
York Tokyo and many
more it's not yet fully understood what
causes Savant syndrome but especially in
the case of those who acquire it it's
believed that compensatory mechanics are
at play when one part of the brain is
damaged another part May develop in an
extraordinary way to compensate linking
previously unlined brain regions that
could unlock superhuman memory
mathematical ability or artistic talent
brain scans of some Sant show highly
unusual connections and activity
patterns that just aren't seen in the
general public this makes sense because
the brain is extremely plastic it can
rewire itself over our lifetimes to
adapt to our environment what we learn
and yes to compensate for injuries
imagine in the brain a little like a
river thoughts and ideas Bubble Up From
the Source and they need to find a way
to get processed by a different part of
the brain and just as water always finds
the path of least resistance in its
inevitable turrent towards the sea forts
try to find the most efficient way to
get actions in the brain so if a brain
injury or A congenital learning or
development disability such as autism
blocks a certain pathway in some cases
the brain will engineer a brand new
pathway way or expand existing Pathways
so they have more bandwidth just like a
river cutting through a new section of
mountain because of a boulder blocking
its original path and with some luck it
might just be that this new pathway is
significantly more efficient than the
pre-existing one if one existed at all
whereas before let's say preinjury the
brain might have taken windy country
lanes to recall a memory or attempt to
play the piano post injury the brain
could have built a shiny new Motorway
connecting two parts of the brain that
make recalling those memories are
playing the piano considerably easier
and faster for the individual to
[Music]
master but naturally all of this poses
an exciting question if Sant prove that
the brain can create these new
connections seemingly random to unlock
insane new
abilities why can't we we just instruct
the brain to create them at our whim
forgoing the really unpleasant brain
injury step admittedly that sounds
rather ambitious however if you stick
with me I'll tell you why it's not as
far-fetched as you might think but first
I want to tell you about that bird calm
down it's not that kind of Channel I'm
talking about the Fey kind specifically
the zebra finch zebra finch have a very
specific song that they all share
usually they learn it from their parents
and peers during their early years but
something truly extraordinary happens
when you disrupt that development when a
zebra finch is raised in complete
isolation from birth it will still
develop the ability to sing its unique
song despite never having heard it from
another
Finch it's like you waking up one day
and being able to perfectly execute a
choreograph dance to Taylor Swift's
Shake It heart off without ever once
having listened to terrible pop music in
your life you see scientists believe the
basic structure of this song is
hardcoded into a zebra Finch's
genealogy which makes me think what if
there are similar skills that are
hardcoded into our
genes passed down through countless
Generations it could be no coincidence
that music and art are two of the most
commonly presenting abilities in Sant
these have both been intrinsically woven
into the Fred of human history since the
dawn of time we have always made music
and we have always made art your genes
contain the footprints of millions of
your ancestors and a very high number of
those ancestors will have been talented
with a paintbrush pencil or some random
stone or wood-based musical
instrument could these traces of Genius
be hardcoded deep within your DNA now
this is all extremely theoretical but it
does seem a bit strange that post injury
individuals can suddenly play Advanced
piano pieces without spending the
hundreds of hours typically required to
do so it suggests that the ability to
perform such a complex intricate and
highly skilled feat was somehow lying
dormant within that person and perhaps
the same skill and many others could be
lying dormant in all of us just like the
song of the zebra
finch so obviously the question arises
how do we purposely unlock these skills
there are emerging technologies that
could be adapted to that very task one
is transcranial magnetic stimulation TMs
in TMS the patient has a coil attached
to his head and magnetic pulses are
passed through the brain to temporarily
alter brain activity it's typically used
to treat depressive disorder or OCD but
it could at least theoretically be
adapted to induce Sant likee qualities
on
demand another option is deep brain
stimulation it's similar to TMs in that
electric pulses are methodically applied
to the brain except a physical pacemaker
like device is inserted into the cranium
to deliver the treatment in a more
permanent and targeted manner it's
typically used to treat epilepsy and
Parkinson's disease but with more
research it could be adapted to induce
Sant likee Connections in the brain to
unlock latent talents in some
individuals or perhaps increase the
capability of one's memory you could
essentially become Rainman without
having to fart in a single phone
box looking into the far future it's
more likely that Gene editing or nano
technology will be used to edit our
brain structure in doing so we might one
day be able to edit our brains in a
computer in a way that that enhances
existing talents or unlocks new ones
then upload this new version to our
brains Matrix style obviously first we
need to fully understand how the brain
works which we currently don't the idea
of using gene editing or other Tech to
modify our thought pattern seems like
pure science fiction but then again
science fiction becoming science reality
seems to become a bit of a trend of late
so you never know although it's much
more like ly that instead of trying to
modify our brains in a sort of natural
way to induce better memory or
superhuman math abilities we will
instead choose to augment our brains
with technology such as computer chip
implants whatever the future holds
though just remember how incredible it
is that we don't have to wait for it to
arrive because we can Marvel at there
are remarkable sants out there right now
that show us all what the human brain is
true truly capable of and you know what
it's nice to know that when hurdles are
put in our way sometimes the brain and
the body are both capable of flying
right over them and ascending to
seemingly impossible
Heights thanks for watching just a quick
word to say that I couldn't make these
videos without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting me on
patreon it's a great place to discuss my
videos with like-minded individuals and
myself the Link's in the description but
if you don't want to or you can't join
my patreon then please don't worry a
simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you